my mother was a wits and I I know that I
said my favorite of her sayings was the
one about the bloated monk who feared
his vow of silence covered farts but I
didn't have a way with the phrase I'm
not afraid I'll word it brung another
time sorry a woods rewards silence this
is the silence we hear things not of
this world
I love Shia
must step very carefully
here yeah
are you nervous of what you will find
when you reach my Noma
[Music]
perhaps
[Music]
which means your no surprise as long
it's fine
yeah everywhere on my double mat this
time of year there are nice many Hawks
which also eat the mice but prefer to be
the snakes and sometimes get both there
is also another creature the Menace's
the mole the child of my housekeeper
Maria this is one of the surprises I
will warn you up now you have a
housekeeper I depend on her she is a
when dead woman she may test you she
mental curses at you then you must put
her in her place she has long since
forgotten at her place I'm afraid dumb I
will tell you the story of the wasp that
followed me for two days
[Music]